move on now to the january 6
congressional committee investigating
the attack on the capitol that panel
will begin to make its case to the
american people tonight live on
primetime television on almost every
channel it comes after nearly a year of
looking into and conducting a thousand
interviews scott mcfarland is following
all of it for us scott good morning
again hey tony good morning to you while
so many of the images from that day are
burned into our minds the committee says
what we've seen and learned so far is
just the beginning in a few hours this
january 6 select committee begins to
reveal its unprecedented investigation
into a deadly attack here at the capitol
the capital siege is already the largest
criminal investigation in american
history
five people dead more than 800
defendants charged weapons tactical gear
looting members of congress running for
their lives even a gallows and a
confederate flag the january sixth house
select committee has spent the last year
investigating more than just the attack
but what and who gave rise to it
president trump and his team
moved willfully through multiple means
to attempt to halt the peaceful transfer
of power the committee has completed
more than one thousand interviews and
gathered more than 140 000 records
despite a boycott and fierce criticism
by nearly all republicans this election
was stolen the committee says former
president donald trump was part of a
criminal conspiracy to defraud the
united states key figures in his
administration including former chief of
staff mark meadows and advisers dan
scavino peter navarro and steve bannon
defied subpoenas and refused to talk
navarro and bannon are facing criminal
prosecution for contempt of congress
prosecutors elected not to charge
meadows and scovino all of this is noise
but others in the inner circle did speak
including rudy giuliani and former
attorney general william barr and the
former president's family members donald
trump jr ivanka trump and jared kushner
cbs news has learned the committee has
deployed a series of investigative teams
a gold team focused on trump's
leadership group a blue team focused on
security failures the delayed military
response and police
the purple team on domestic violent
extremism and the role of social media a
green team following money trails and a
red team investigating the rioters and
their planning they've collected phone
records and text messages including some
sent by house republican colleagues to
mark meadows about plans to challenge
the presidential election results the
amount of data scott is absolutely
stunning it maybe is the biggest data
effort in the history of congressional
investigations former january 6th
committee investigator denver rigelman
says the hearings are designed to tell a
story what's the big message you believe
the committee is trying to put out there
one word coordination
and whether you're taking rally
organizers or you're taking those
individuals who actually stormed the
capital right-wing extremist groups what
they're trying to show is coordination
one of the first witnesses will be a
documentarian who is tracking the
movements of the far right proud boys
and some oath keepers here january 6th
they're charged with conspiracy to block
the peaceful transfer of power we also
expect to hear taped excerpts of
depositions with some witnesses
including members of former president
trump's family ivanka trump and jared
kushner tony
i do hope people tune in scott thank you
very much